رئيس هيئة الاركان الامريكية لا
يوجد سلاح سحري يمكن ان تستخدمه
اوكرانيا لتنتصر على روسيا.
وبامر عاجل من بوتين الدليفري
الروسي يوصل اسلحته النووية الى
فيلاروسيا. وباجنر تعلن انسحابها
من باخموت معلنة النهاية. وفي
الجو اندلعت حرب اوكرانية روسية
من نوع اخر. فما الذي يجري?
مجزرة المليارات بين الاتحاد
الاوروبي وروسيا. والتسريبات
الامريكية تورط كييف مرة اخرى
وهذه المرة مع بوتين شخصيا
والرئيس الروسي يطلق وحش
المحيطات لمواجهة التمدد
الامريكي. بينما واشنطن وسيول
تستثيران شهية زعيم كوريا
الشمالية عسكريا. واخيرا ها هو
كيم ينحني امام شخص. فمن هو هذا
الشخص واليابان تتحضر انضمامه
لحلف الناتو. حروب القوى العظمى
تشتعل. الحرب تطول والاحداث
تتسارع والتوترات مع الغرب
تتصاعد. ليبدأ بوتين اولى خطواته
النووية ويضع قدميه على الاراضي
البلاروسية على الحدود
الاوروبية. وهنا تصمت الالسنة
ليبدأ الحديث للاقلام. حيث وقع
وزيرا الدفاع الروسي والبيلاروسي
على وثائق تحدد نشر الاسلحة
النووية غير الاستراتيجية في
بلاروسيا ليعلن رئيس بلاروسيا
الكسندر لوكيشينكو ان نقل بعض
الاسلحة النووية التكتيكية من
روسيا الى بلاروسيا قد بدأ
بالفعل حسب ما ذكرت وكالة تاس
للانباء. من جهته قال وزير
الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويغا ان
روسيا بنشرها اسلحة نووية غير
استراتيجية على اراضي بلاروسيا
لا تنقلها للجمهورية وانما
التحكم بها وقرار استخدامها يبقى
بيد موسكو وفق جميع الالتزامات
القانونية والدولية القائمة. ومن
التحرك النووي الروسي الى
المباغتة النووية الاوكرانية.
حيث صرح جهاز الامن الفيدرالي
الروسي انه احبط ما وصفها بعملية
تخريب اوكرانية كانت تستهدف
محطات نووية في التاسع من مايو
الجاري. فهل تجرأ الاوكران حقا
على التحرش بالمحطات النووية
يشعل كارثة عالمية اخرى بعد
كارثة تشيرنوبيل والتي لم يخمد
دخانها حتى اليوم. ومع اصوات
الرصاص واستمرار المعارك ها هو
قائد مجموعة فاجنيري في جيني
بريجوجن يعلن تسليم دفة القيادة
الى قيادة الجيش الروسي معلنا
انتهاء مهمته بتحرير باخموت.
مضيفا ان عملية التسليم ستنتهي
قبل الاول من يونيو وفق تعبيره.
فيما اعلنت وزارة الدفاع الروسية
في لها القضاء على ستمائة وستين
جنديا اوكرانيا على مختلف محاور
القتال في منطقة العملية
العسكرية الخاصة. اضافة لتدمير
عشرات الاليات المختلفة. ليعلن
البنتاجونما واشنطن وافقت على
صفقة محتملة لبيع احد انظمة
الدفاع الجوي من طراز ناسامز
حارسة البيت الابيض الى اوكرانيا
بقيمة مائتين وخمسة وثمانين
مليون دولار. ليضيف ان اوكرانيا
لديها حاجة ملحة لبناء اسلحة
للدفاع ضد الضربات الصاروخية
والجوية الروسية. ولكن السؤال
الاهم هو متى ستسدد كييف
الفاتورة. لتأتي الاجابة على
لسان رئيس الاركان الامريكي
الجنرال مارك ميلي مصرحا بقوله
انه لا يوجد سلاح سحري يمكن ان
تستخدمه اوكرانيا لتنتصر على
روسيا بما في ذلك مقاتل ستة عشر.
فهل هو تهرب من امداد كييف
بالطائرات ام ان ميلي يقول
الحقيقة ويا لها من حقيقة مرة.
من جهة اخرى قال مستشار الرئيس
الاوكراني ان الهجوم المضاد ضد
القوات الروسية قد بدأ بالفعل
منذ عدة ايام ومستمر حاليا.
واوضح المسئول الاوكراني ان هناك
حربا مكثفة واسعة النطاق تدور في
الوقت الراهن على مدى نحو الف
وخمسمائة كيلومتر من الحدود
الاوكرانية الروسية. لتعود بنا
الاحداث الى معارك المليارات.
حيث صرح ممثل المفوضية الاوروبية
كريستيان بوجن بان الدول الاعضاء
في الاتحاد الاوروبي جمدت اكثر
من مائتي مليار يورو من اصول
البنك المركزي الروسي. لتفيد
صحيفة فاينشال تايمز البريطانية
بان الاتحاد الاوروبي يبحث سبل
تحويل مليارات اليوروهات من
عوائد الاصول الروسية المجمدة
اوكرانيا فليسكت الدب الروسي عن
خطوة كهذه ومن مجزرة الاقتصاد
المحفوفة بالمخاطر الى حرب جديدة
اندلعت مؤخرا بين موسكو وكيه.
انها معارك الطيور المتسكعة يا
سادة. حيث قال حاكم القرن
الموالي لروسيا انه تم اسقاط ست
مسيرات اوكرانية في مناطق مختلفة
من شبه الجزيرة. ومن جهتها افادت
السلطات الاوكرانية ان دفاعاتها
مسيرة هجومية روسية في كييف
وميكولييف واوديسا. هناك حذرت
السلطات الاوكرانية من خطر هجوم
بطائرات مسيرة روسية على كييف.
داعية سكان العاصمة للبقاء في
الملاجئ حتى انتهاء التحذير.
وعلى ذات السياق كشف مسئولون
امريكيون انهم اعترضوا مكالمات
بين مسؤولين اوكرانيين يلقون
خلالها باللوم على بعضهم البعض
بشأن الهجوم مسيرة على الكرملين
لمحاولة اغتيال بوتين وذلك وفق
شبكة سي ان ان الامريكية. كانت
قد نفت صلتها بالهجوم. لتأتي
تسريبات الامريكان وتورطهم. فهل
يتم اثبات هذه التسريبات? وبين
هذا وذاك موسكو تحرك وحش
المحيطات. حيث تستعد احدث غواصة
في البحرية الروسية للتوجه الى
قاعدة دائمة في منطقة المحيط
الهادئ مواجهة ما تصفه موسكو
بالتمدد الامريكي. الغواصة والتي
تعمل بالطاقة النووية ومزودة
بصواريخ باليستية يمكنها حمل
رؤوس نووية. الاحداث والتطورات.
بدأ الجيشان الكوري الجنوبي
والامريكي تدريبات عسكرية
بالذخيرة الحية هي الاضخم من
نوعها بالقرب من الحدود مع كوريا
الشمالية. وتأتي هذه التدريبات
مرور سبعين عاما على انشاء
التحالف العسكري بين سول وواشنطن
وذلك رغم تحذير كوريا الشمالية
بانها لن تتسامح مع ما تصفه
بتجربة غزو قرب اراضيها. هذه
الصورة طال انتظارها. نعم انه
مشهد لم يحدث من قبل. زعيم كوريا
الشمالية ينحني ولاول مرة وذلك
امام قبر احد الاشخاص ليتبين ان
القبر يعود للجنرال يونج صديقه
وحارس العائلة. واذا عرف السبب
بطل العجب كم يبادل صديقه الوفاء
بالوفاء. اليابان لديها جزر
متنازع عليها مع روسيا وتخوفا من
تكرار تجربة اوكرانيا قال رئيس
الوزراء الياباني ان بلاده لا
تخطط للانضمام الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي الناتو ولكنه اقر بخطط
الحلف لفتح مكتب اتصال في
اليابان. الى حيث كشفت وزارة
الدفاع عن صاروخ باليستي جديد
يحمل اسم خيبر وهو نسخة معدلة من
الصاروخ رمشار والذي تصل سرعته
بحسب وزارة الدفاع الايرانية الى
ستة عشر ماخ اي ستة عشر ضعفا من
سرعة الصوت خارج الغلاف الجوي
وثمانية ماخ داخل الغلاف الجوي.
ويبلغ مدى صاروخ الفي كيلومتر
ويحمل رأسا حربيا يبلغ وزنه الفا
وخمسمائة كيلو جرام. واوضحت
الوزارة بان الصاروخ يصعب
استهدافه من قبل انظمة الدفاع
الجوي بسبب سرعته الفيقة.
برأيكم؟ هل هذه المواصفات
واقعية؟ او كما يقولها العرب؟
الهرج نصف القتال. لقد قالها
الامريكان ليس لدينا حل سحري
لاوكرانيا. فما هو الحل اذا
لانتصار الاوكران اذا كان هذا هو
كلام الامريكان.